[Musique]
depuis 11 mois vous redoutiez ce jour
monsieur mais il est arrivé le 1er août
et vous accompagnez votre femme jusqu'au
train qui l'emmène vers de belles
vacances pendant que vous vous restez au
bureau vous ressortez seul est désolé
face à un paris désert et sans tendresse
à midi vous déjeuner à la terrasse d'un
café un sandwich suffit après le café
vous écrivez à votre femme que vous
accompagnez par la pensée et non du
regard
à 6h vous sortez du bureau vous faites
vos courses
le pain et les gâteaux d'abord le
bifteck ensuite
le vin enfin
à le bon dîner en perspective
est-ce que vous avez pris goût à la
cuisine que vous faites est ce que quand
votre femme sera en grève vous me direz
tient ce soir je vais faire la cuisine
peut-être prudemment non pas lui donner
une mauvaise habitude
bon la vaisselle vous la faites vous
même un oui mais en bloc et
j'attends qu'ils aient vraiment un très
gros tas sur l'évier l'attendait comme
un jour non je sais pas je veux pas
chercher à savoir actuellement est ce
que vous êtes en vie en mesure de me
dire qu'on veille à d'assiette empilés
dans votre évier non pas les touches
peut pas imaginer
ceci vous amène au samedi midi le bureau
vous laisse libre jusqu'au lundi matin
vous allez en profiter pour faire
quelques achats pour porter votre linge
chez votre teinturier
et pour faire arranger et une chaussure
qui vous fait mal
puis vous rentrez chez vous ou le ménage
vous attend
chez vous les problèmes de ménage avait
y en a pas y'en a pas de problème non il
n'ya pas de ménage quand ya pas de
système
alors la poussière dans la poussière
j'en vois pas beaucoup
samedi 18h sur les champs elysées
vous vous apercevez que vous n'avez pas
encore écrit à votre femme vous couvrez
le fer
et le 30 août finie la solitude madame
est annoncée vous allez la chercher à la
gare et vous êtes contents parce que
outre 64 est terminée et que août 65 et
dans onze mois
[Musique]